c'est l'un des plus beaux l'un des plus
étranges aussi avec ses rochers c'est
escarpements le parc des buttes chaumont
l'un des lieux favoris de promenade des
parisiens trois millions et demi de
visiteurs par an mais c'est aussi l'un
des plus mal en point
éboulements fissures 132 ans après son
ouverture le parc a beaucoup vieilli un
projet de rénovation vient d'être lancé
ce pic par exemple est en train de
s'effondrer
ce pic s'est érodée et donc maintenant
on sent très nettement qu'il a tendance
à partir et a basculé dans le lac et
c'est la raison pour laquelle on va le
le reconstituer dans sa configuration
d'origine
alors ici c'est encore une des zones
caractéristiques du parc
cette grande falaise qui est con poti
sur lesquelles on voit des jardinières
en encorbellement et jardinières tombe
et donc pour seul qui reste bien en
place il ya un grand danger et donc nous
allons supprimer toutes ces jardinières
et pour retrouver l'aspect du parc à son
origine
nous allons reconstituer les jardinières
la rénovation débutera d'ici trois ans
en tout près de 500 millions de francs
seront investis
nous savions parfaitement que si nous ne
prenions pas en priorité la restauration
de ce parc
toute une partie étaient fermés dans les
cinq années qui viennent il y a urgence
il y a urgence parce que nous sommes sur
un sol qui est fragile et qui au fur et
à mesure que les années ont passé s'est
affaissé un concours va être lancée par
la ville pour désigner l'architecte
en tout les travaux dureront près de six
ans